India the world's biggest democracy 29
states seven territories 900 million
voters and one age-old fault line
nationalism this is an idea that will
return the damage done but erase it
spitting Hindus against Muslims and
other minorities and putting India's
long tradition of secularism under
threat anomic ax is one of the 1 billion
Hindus living in India she's 23 and
studying for a degree in physics today
she's leaving a rally to get students to
vote in the country's upcoming general
election a beautiful naked a cotillion
of allocation a Muhammad Ali banja or
khuda reform non elegant president I'm
Kelly Abby selfie a request some lucha
return after a keyboard button ah mika
doesn't want these students to vote for
just anyone
she's actually the modern face of a vast
hindi nationalist group India becoming a
Hindu nation is important because ever
since the beginning of civilization only
this geographical area has always been
of Hindus our youth should know about
our glorious past the culture and our
traditions our culture's because for a
lot of time the youth has been blinded
by the modernization and the different
cultures anomic who lives in Uttar
Pradesh it's one of the most socially
divided and religiously diverse states
in India
olam is one of the 190 million Muslims
living in India a father of three his
family have been butchers in Uttar
Pradesh for generations in loom Salman
sickies I sublet bravura other couch
along is called torn epilogue away
induced on kiss titicaca netiquette cook
on your career
ki sthithi about Karachi city jong-kul
coach teach me only one Lydia Darragh
God would you suddenly hear Hindu Muslim
tensions are on the rise in 2019 but
they're by no means new these tensions
run deep into the country's history in
1947 with India preparing for
independence from British rule the
country was hastily partitioned into two
separate nations the creation of
Pakistan was a response to Muslim
nationalist anxious about living under a
Hindu majority millions were killed or
displaced as people fled to the new
Muslim state or to India which portrayed
itself as a secular alternative
today that secular alternative is under
pressure not least in a conflict
embodied by the Hindu faiths most sacred
animal here we are at gorakhnath temple
there are almost 300 to 400 cows and
they are fed daily baby every day cows
holds a very important place for a Hindu
we don't consider it as an animal also
we treat it as a mother over the past
few years India's Hindu led government
has pressed for strict enforcement of
laws against anyone slaughtering cows or
selling beef action should be taken
against those people who is still
slaughter and smuggle the cows after all
the restrictions because they are just
trying to play with our beliefs and they
are trying to mock our way of living the
more hardline approach has hit Muslim
and minority communities hard businesses
that deal with any kind of beef have
been shut down they've been accused of
flouting the law and some have faced
even worse consequences across the
country Calva jalan t gang has killed 44
people 38 of them muslim between 2015
and 2018
[Music]
good luck time by Aamir Khan chorus part
of our said I with Darwin a year
Kika hindu-muslim karaage hasaki Marmol
a Wilma Honda we understand
last year India saw a rise in hate crime
attacks against minorities it was the
largest number of incidents in a decade
then early in 2019 another historic
flashpoint stoked tensions further in
February a Pakistan terror group claimed
it launched an attack in the Indian
controlled part of Kashmir killing 40
soldiers India responded by bombing what
it said was a terrorist training camp in
Pakistan it had a profound effect across
India
this is an idea that will return the
demo done but there is interest
Prime Minister Narendra Modi and his
party the BJP have nurtured the sense of
threat to Hindi security and culture
ahead of the national election Modi was
trying to galvanize Hindi's who make up
80 percent of India's population
anam occur and the hindered for nationís
movement that provide Modi's power base
are taking that message out
Noreen mode is one of the best PM India
has ever had he can also be as terrible
as hell if you are messing with the
peacefulness of the country he is only
got the potential to protect the
citizens of the country from outer
attacks as well as the inner attacks
mitanni look Kanhaiya Hindustan under
history kg of watt a global um
caretakers Kirk a Muslim for awara go
torture Chiara which world is a toate
Nadia which Khadija to Pakistan's
in Uttar Pradesh alumns now trying to
run a fruit juice business where his
butcher shop once stood but he's
struggling to pay the bills he's
recently had to take his sisters and
children out of school like barky party
atonality a Hindu what avec asked an
ample - Monty come sir Kevin I think I'm
not doing anything I'm Cora warding all
Joey Lohan do in dupa city would want a
Hindu endowed city Modi first came to
power as a moderniser
with the promise of jobs and prosperity
for India but as the economy slowed
unemployment began to rise so too did
his support for the nationalist agenda
where he leads India next to further
division or back towards the country's
historic secularism remains to be seen
when a Hindu Muslim Salonika Lata Hossam
lineage araga top condesa conduct
aggregate of enoch with chaga
[Music]
you
you